الفضاء الدكتور عصام حجي دكتور اسئله
كثيره تثار الان فيما يتعلق
لنبداها لماذا منطاد اذا كان فعلا للتجسس
وليس عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه
هي في نقطه مهمه
انه الصين لها عدد مهول من الاقمار
الصناعيه التي تستطيع ان تحصل بها على
المعلومات اذا لماذا هو المنطاد يعني انا
مش انا هنا اتمنى ان احنا نشوف الاجهزه
الموجوده فيه وبعد كده نشوف اذا كان فعلا
للتجارب العلميه او كانوا يستخدم في
الدجاجه اسوس المنطاد بشكل عام
الاجهزه اكبر ويستطيع استحداث
وسائل جديده للاستشعار والتجربه في المنط
اد
الصناعيه اذا ميزه المنطاد ان هو بوابه
لاطلاق اجهزه استشعار حديثه في المستقبل
على الاقمار الصناعيه وهنشوف خلال الايام
الجايه تحليل الاجهزه الموجوده على هذا
المنطاد هي اللي هتقول لنا يعني ما نوع
المهمه التي كان فيها هذا المنطاد وارى
انه في حاله التوتر الموجوده في الان يعني
يمكن بسبب التضارب المعلومات
زي ما بنشوف من من الاخوه الضيوف
الموجودين ولكن علينا ان ننتظر ماذا كان
يحمل هذا المضاد من اجهزه طيب ايضا مما
اثير من الاسئله من خلال هذه التغطيه هو
كيف استطاع هذا المنطاد سواء كان ضالا
لطريقه او متقصدا لطريقه قطع كل هذه
المسافه وتصوير اماكن حساسه كما يقول
الجانب الامريكي ومن ثم تم الاعلان عن
رصده هل بالامكان ان يتجاوز ما لدى
الولايات المتحده من تكنولوجيا متطوره
للرقابه والرصد
اولا شيء مهم يجب اللي احنا نشوف انه
ارتفاع اللي بيطير عليه هذا المنطاد
بيجعله اضمن ليس من السهل ان هو يكون في
اجهزه
الرادار اثنين التكوين بتاع الماده اللي
فيها المنطاد وليس من الحديد
وبالتالي الجزء المعدني الموجود فيه ممكن
ما يسهلش برضو انه الرادارات العاديه التي
تستخدم في الملاحه الجويه تستطيع رؤيته
بسهوله ولكن تم فعلا دراسه هذا المنطاد من
وتم التعرف ان هو منتظمه داخل ولكن
الارتفاع الذي هو موجود عليه لا يجعله
يمثل اي نوع من الخطوره ولم يتعرف على
يعني من اين من اي مكان ينتمي هذا المنطاد
وعايز اقول برضو نقطه اوضح فيها انه
التحكم في المناطيط ضعيف جدا وليست هذه
المره الاولى الذي يتم فيها خروج منطاد عن
مساره والسؤال ايضا الاهم هو لماذا هم هذه
المهمه فيها منطاد في امريكا الجنوبيه
ومنطات امريكا الشماليه اعتقد ان ده
السؤال السؤال الاكبر والاهم واذا كان هم
الاثنين طلعوا من من الاتجاه اللي كان
محدد لهم بسبب التغير في الرياح او كانت
هذه التجربه او هذه المهمه
تلزم وجود من طادين وكل هذه الصعب الاجابه
عليها قبل ما نشوف الاجهزه اللي كانت
موجوده على المنطقه طيب دي اشارتك الى اجل
الدكتور عصام
ما الذي يميز اجهزه
للتجسس عن اجهزه لاغراض علميه كما يقول
الجانب الصيني
عن اقل من المنطاد
بالمقارنه بالتصوير من الاقمار الصناعيه
او بنتكلم عن التصوير البسيط بشكل عام
ولكن ان ننسى ان هذا هذا المنطاد هو يعبر
مناطق مغطاه بالسحب في اغلبها هو لا يعبر
مناطق في مناطق الصحراويه والجافه التي
التي ليست هي مغطاه
بالسحب اذا فكره التصوير في حده هاتها
هنعرف من الاجهزه اذا كان يقوم بالتصوير
او لا ولكن التجارب الا
هم
الدراسات الخاصه بالغلاف الجوي او
الدراسات الخاصه لو
باستشعار المجال
الكهرومغناطيسي الموجود في هذه الطبقات في
الغلاف الجوي والذي يساعد في تطوير
تكنولوجيا الاتصالات الحديده مثلا ويساعد
في لو كان حد
فاكيد
على الاتصالات
الاكثر من
شيء معين في هذه المنطقه